The short answer I would say is anyone.
But the real answer I think is almost
anyone.
Um,
I am very comfortable with the system
that for a very acute period of time
protects people from their own worst
instincts.
But I do mean a very acute period of
time.
I think the power dogmatic and Campbell,
if someone you might want to prevent
from committing suicide is the teenager
who breaks up with a boyfriend or
girlfriend and tries to overdose on
tylenol and to tell them for a few days
we're going to hospitalize you against
your will.
Listen,
see men unreasonable to me.
In contrast,
someone who has suffered from chronic
depression throughout their life with
multiple suicide attempts.
Clearly modern medicine,
modern psychiatry has been unable to
help this person.
Um,
while I wouldn't necessarily choose to
end my life under those circumstances,
I be respect someone else's right to do
so.
So the real standard I would use is does
this person on the one hand have
capacity to make this decision?
Are they thinking clearly?
Are they thinking rationally?
And secondly,
can they demonstrate this capacity over
a prolonged period of several days
rather than being in an instant?
And I think the vast majority of people
who wish to commit suicide wouldn't eat
most of the both of those criteria.